what is this game sup bro you know
what's up brother it's been eight days
and you still haven't recalibrated your
puzzles what are you even doing hey take
it easy I gotten a ton of work done
today a scale a ton ah I will attend to
my possible as for your work put your
little more backbone into it yeah I am
my gosh that lives inside of Dominic
human I'll skate your soul out of your
body
oh god it's one of those meanings I got
damn boy you [ __ ] hardcore man I'm
out of names hahaha now I hate making
promises but that promise I made to her
you know what would have happened if she
hadn't said anything buddy you'd be dead
where you stand
hey latin ah Paco I'm just joking me
besides haven't I done a great job
protecting you I mean look at yourself
you haven't died a single time hey
what's that look supposed to me am I
wrong